if he's if he's pushing then i
okay uh my back foot is that is the
groundbreaking
push okay that's where i want my weight
to be
if he's pulling then the front foot
as is pushing he's just making that foot
heavy
okay so he goes to push
and i will ground the front foot and
then
i'll project myself off of him this way
he goes to push no no
so don't try to pull with your shoulders
go into that ground
whoa i'm projecting myself off into the
into the ground boom
i'm not shifting my weight i'll never be
able to do that
i will not be able to hit he's going to
pull me i have to ground that
look where his grip is okay this is what
i'm trying to do i'm trying to push this
out like that so i'm not trying to work
against his fingers push
out boom
elbow and rest
[Music]
up to now we've been doing a lot of the
back the back foot
vectoring okay and now now we're doing
the front
the front flip okay
my front foot is doing the vector
so i'm not doing it like this
i'll show you what i mean okay so
uh of course he could he could feel
the force okay but i'm gonna show you
something something else so
when i'm on the front foot and he pulls
you you see how you're just grounding my
front foot more
you see that and so as he pulls
do see what it's doing to his balance
you see
as opposed to like i'm going like that
or i'm trying to go like this which
actually braces him
you see well i do my front foot
he resists it'll make him move because
it's pulling
on his line of gravity okay so when
we're here
i do the first one is the front foot and
then
it stays on
so front foot front foot
boom and then stays on the front
[Music]
once once your angle cancellation has
been generated
then you can move but you see that's not
what's moving here
or changing our relationship so front
foot
front
boom and i stay on the front foot i'm
vectoring off from the front
i'll off the front
here boom and i vector
[Music]
awful
don't don't get him off and then you
keep him with his balance
so i do have his elbow i do have his
wrist
and i just sort of do this with my
ground vector
oh
oh may i come up to that
[Music]
oh
in my head
[Music]
okay so he you know if if i can get my
grip on him
if i can get my grips on him then then i
can take him down
so you don't want to be grip okay
so just a basic uh grip escape
hey go two on one vector off the front
foot
okay hey let's work on keep vectoring
off the front foot so
it's not that i'm pulling him but he was
he was pulling me so that creates that
that kazushi without me pulling on him
i just keep vectoring off and he's going
there oh
heads over here continue the condition
this is a series of drills
here
come here
[Music]
so
you can't change stance i go back
and i put the other new foot where the
other foot is
and i have not entered so i could do it
on a circle
if i wanted to okay so boom meaning
we're gonna go this way see that
what you're looking for is less mass of
hand to throw
so take it on a circle
so front foot long wool
circle and then you're actually going
forward
boom oh i'm gonna go forward
he goes forward and around and
forward and around i'm going slow help
me out
boom boom forward and around
they want your no help anymore
[Music]
hey